[Music]
from the very beginning the human race
has had to contend with problems of
survival disease and death through the
ages entire populations were decimated
and became extinct leaving behind only
scant remnants of their cultures
[Music]
[Applause]
difficult to establish at what point in
history medicine appeared but we have
some record of diseases being treated in
various parts of the world as far back
as two thousand years BC throughout the
centuries navigation was developed with
the movement of people around the planet
terrifying epidemics of cholera yellow
fever and plague began to spread nation
has gradually realized that there was a
need to fight these diseases together
and in 1851 the first international
health conference was held in Paris
in 1919 a new strain of influenza
strapping more victims in a few months
and had been killed throughout the First
World War the League of Nations did
consider health issues but it was only
after the Second World War that a United
Nations conference drew up the plan for
a separate international health body in
September 1947 when cholera broke out in
Egypt the World Health Organisation's
sprang into action it couldn't afford to
wait for its formal Constitution which
was signed on April 7th 1948 days since
celebrated globally as World Health Day
in June 1948 the first World Health
Assembly opened in Geneva with 53
countries represented the suffering of
millions of human beings and scores of
countries will be alleviated and many
many thousands of lives will be saved
quarantine regulations but rone up to
curb the spread of communicable diseases
but the root causes of ill health also
had to be tackled the only enemies worth
fighting are ill health poverty and
ignorance malaria a widespread fatal
disease was one of the top priorities
facing a new organization
in the early 1950s spectacular successes
were achieved through a systematic
spraying with DDT in 1955 fearful that
the mosquitoes would develop resistance
to the spraying the World Health
Organization launched a global campaign
to eradicate malaria
the dream was not to be by the late 60s
it was clear eradication was not
possible controlling malaria was a more
realistic approach snare Hawks one out
of four people it touched died
the rest were marked for life millions
were affected in 1958 countries started
massive vaccination campaigns to wipe
out the disease worldwide but to
vaccinate every man woman and child on
earth proved an overwhelming task in
1967 the World Health Organization
launched a new campaign with a different
approach contain the disease that each
outbreak stop the chain of transmission
every case had to be tracked down all
who had been in contact had to be found
unvaccinated
the search went on everywhere in schools
public places through person-to-person
contacts even financial rewards were
offered for those reporting cases the
question was asked over and over again
have you seen anyone who looks like this
[Music]
step-by-step the disease was pushed back
to the very last case
Ali Mao Molly
with an e a chain of transmission as old
as mankind was broken smallpox was no
named on the 8th of May 1980
dr. Hoffman Marla director-general of
the World Health Organization signed a
certificate of eradication the 10-year
campaign cost 300 million dollars a real
bargain the world saved each year 1000
million dollars on vaccines in carapace
it alone the saving in human suffering
has no place important as the
elimination of smoke ox was hundreds of
millions in the less developed countries
were still trapped in a vicious cycle of
poverty and disease most people had no
access to basic health care average life
expectancy hovered at 50 many mothers
died in childbirth and many children
like these died before reaching
adolescence
[Music]
something had to be done a new effective
long-term plan that would benefit
everyone and health for all by the year
2000 was the gold set of the World
Health Assembly in 1977 a year later the
where head was declared at Alma Arta in
villages such as this one a new vision
began to take root a vision based on
primary health care that is health for
people in their home of schools villages
where they live and work a vision based
on local men and women trained to care
for common health problems forty years
ago the World Health Organization was
created to help build a healthier world
where are we today world population has
reached the five billion mark remarkable
progress has been made in science and
medicine yet the health picture varies
widely in industrialized nations many
millions are invested in medical
technology but blatant inequalities in
health status remain
[Music]
high technology takes us ahead it also
takes it for example nuclear accidents
as lasting threats to in response to
these dangers groups are demanding
control over their health and
individuals are taking personal action
in the poorer nations the picture is
very different three-quarters of the
world's population received less than
10% of the world's budget for health
women have a 200 times greater risk of
dying during pregnancy and childbirth
than women in the rich nations while
these countries still face the diseases
of poverty they must learn to confront
the diseases of affluence fueled by the
adoption of Western lifestyles alcohol
and tobacco use surged upward sewed of
heart disease and cancer rates for the
first time in their history these
countries must battle yesterday's and
tomorrow's diseases at the same time
today the world is facing a grave new
threat the AIDS virus we don't know
where it came from but we do know that
it brings suffering and death
[Music]
more than half of the people diagnosed
with AIDS have died
fortunately it can only spread from one
person to the next in a few ways
sex blood and from mother to child the
AIDS virus is already present on every
continent government's acting
individually cannot stop its spread the
only way it can be stopped in any
country is for it to be stopped in all
countries from w-h-o the call has now
gone out to the family of Nations two
nations and two individuals a call that
says that we know how to stop AIDS and
what is now required is that responsible
actions take place at the individual the
national and the international level
over the past 40 years the World Health
Organization has shown can be achieved
through international cooperation
eradication of smallpox a major
reduction in child mortality through
immunization and anti diarrheal disease
control a confidence to promote safe
which aim to have maternal deaths in
developing countries by the end of the
century control of tuberculosis and
leprosy through treatment at home and
many other similar low-cost solutions to
URIs delusion these gains the millions
of lives saved and the untold suffering
avoided have been achieved through
involving people in their own
cooperation between countries research
and proper use of appropriate technology
strengthening health systems and health
intonation that is through WH OHS
primary health care approach
[Music]
over the past 40 years we have learned
the difficulty in W ed so that
development and that includes of course
health development cannot be achieved by
proxy it has to be carried out by the
people concerned themselves but to help
them do that in a self-reliant way wso
has shown them how much they themselves
can do to improve their own health and
so it has promoted research and
development leading to a string of
low-cost technologies that can be
adapted to different social economic and
cultural situations and afford it even
by the poorest countries but most
important wso has shown how to set up
the permanent structures required in the
health and many other sectors to make
sure that technology becomes accessible
to the masses and not just to the
privileged few the al matter declaration
on primary health care now ten years old
clearly mapped out the road on which we
are firmly engaged people everywhere
from north to south east to west
recognize beyond all the differences
that health is good for all people and
essentially indeed for human progress
that there is both economic value
and social justice in health sure we
must all recognize that even offense is
not everything
there is nothing will actress in the
interest of the human race
there must be health for all and all for
health
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]